they waved to our cameras delighted to
be in uk waters
we tracked the same group to the beach
in the kent town of lead how's your
journey today sir
how'd you speak
the migrants know they will be met by
the emergency services and medical help
if it's needed
it is this process which the prime
minister has vowed to break through
deterrence promising to send tens of
thousands of male and female asylum
seekers to rwanda for processing or a
new life
we must first ensure that the only route
to asylum
to in the uk is a safe and legal one and
that those who try to jump the cue or
abuse our system
will find no automatic path to
settlement in our country exactly as
boris johnson was speaking in dover a
baby was amongst the migrants brought
ashore at the port
in future the government wants to screen
those arriving through an illegal route
and via a safe country such as france
i think we need to see these plans for
what they are it's a desperate
announcement by a prime minister who
just wants to distract from his own law
breaking um you know they're unworkable
they're extortionate they're going to
cost taxpayers billions of pounds
with predictions there could soon be a
thousand migrants arriving by small boat
a day the navy and the army have now
been drafted in
but the strategy to tackle the rising
numbers is hugely controversial still to
get through the commons and likely to be
challenged legally
i've seen nothing that provides any
reassurance that people's human rights
are going to be upheld parliament has
been considering the government's
legislation that would allow it to move
forward for this with this plan
for the past few months and the house of
lords has put up huge opposition
for those who remain in the uk a former
raf base in north yorkshire will be
turned into a new reception center with
more than a hundred thousand asylum
seekers there's an accommodation
shortage
five million pounds a day is being spent
on hotel bills alone the government says
the system is broken in birmingham we
met fider from afghanistan who's been
waiting two years for his claim to be
processed he says even the asylum
seekers themselves aren't happy
asylum system is too long phrases
long process no give me money no house
no clothes no shoes in the steamwhite
tent
not helping the daughter yeah someone in
the mentally problem
the prime minister says his plan will
save people from the greed and dangers
of people smugglers but the fact is
everything else to stop the channel
crossings has failed lisa holland sky
news